CHARLIE MCAVOY
BERGERON GETS OFF
BALANCE.
A GREAT .
PATRICE BERGERON
AGAINST FOWLER.
FINDING CARLO. AFTE
BRUINS MANAGE THE
PUCK BEAUTIFULLY UP
THE
AGAINST THE GRAIN,
CHARLIE COYLE GETS
HIS STICK ON IT.
CANNOT CLEAR WASN'T
SUCCESSFUL.
AND WENT AGAINST
THE SECOND ONE.
IT WAS ACTUALLY THE
ANAHEIM.
SO RED LINE.
DEREK GRANT
DEFLECTS DESLAURIER
HAS A RETURN.  CHAN
PASTRNAK MANAGED
QUITE AN GOAL.
>> BRICK: WATCH
THE TOP OF THE AK.
AND HE SCORES!
THAT ONE BETWEEN
THE OM TAKES
THE PUCK TO THE
NET.
TRYING TO PULL
GIVING UP A
SHORTHANDED GOAL TO
FALDO 2-0.
THEY HAD SOME LOOKS
AND SCORES.  AK.
GET HIMSELF INTO PL
MARCHAND.
OFFSIDE CALL.
LOOKING
FOR ANAHEIM.   YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT MIKE
SH
TUUKKA RASK.
>> BRICK: STRO
AND
SCORES!
TROY TERRY Y PUCK
WHEN IT IS IN THE
AIR OR HAVE TO BACK
OFLAF.
RAKELL WITH ONE OF
THE SPACE.
CLOSES.
ZEGRAS CANNOT GET
DUCKS HAVE OPENED H
TO CARLO.
OF THE BOARDS.
THIS IS WHAT YOU
ARE LOOKING FOR.